le proche orient ce matin c'est aussi la
tournée du ministre français des
affaires étrangères dans les pays du
golfe
première étape le koweït où monsieur
françois poncet évoquera dès ce matin
les efforts de paix au proche orient
avec la france souhaite global est aussi
la hausse du pétrole décidé par les pays
de l'opep le ministre français parlera
aussi peut-être de l'agriculture en
effet plusieurs pays arabes utilisent de
plus en plus les devises que le rapporte
le pétrole pour développer leur
agriculture c'est le cas en irak où des
milliers d'hectares de la mésopotamie
sont remis en culture pour fournir
l'alimentation de troupeaux de vaches
laitières des troupeaux installées dans
des fermes ultra moderne comme on en
voit encore très peu en france
d'ailleurs
et c'est pourtant la france qui vient
d'installer entièrement en irak l'une de
ces fermes vendus en somme clés en main
reportage jean françois robin et le
tigre l'un des deux fleuves irrigue la
mésopotamie il traverse la capitale de
l'irak bagdad deux millions d'habitants
près d'un cinquième de l'ensemble de la
population
l'industrie et surtout artisanale
travail du cuivre tapie mais la grande
richesse du pays c'est bien sûr le
pétrole qui permet justement de
moderniser l'agriculture
plus de 60% des irakiens vivent des
produits du sol l'irak est le premier
producteur de dates au monde
lorsqu'il est irrigué grâce aux canaux
qui rejoignent le tigre et l'euphrate
le sol est très fertile mais pour des
raisons diverses
longtemps pays de nomades se contentant
dé lever moutons et chèvres
l'agriculture a été négligée elle fait
aujourd'hui un bond considérable en
avant et en plein désert dans trois
régions du pays le gouvernement irakien
a décidé d'implanter des fermes
ultramoderne la construction de l'une
d'entre elles a été confiée à une
société française d'engineering qui
dépend du groupe national entreprises
minières et chimiques
la ferme d'al-khalis abrite déjà 1500
têtes de bétail ce projet parmi d'autres
a pu aboutir grâce à la forte
implantation dans le monde de la société
commerciale des potasses d'alsace
filiale du groupe emc cela en étroite
collaboration avec beck engineering
nous nous efforçons effectivement de
mettre au service de cette espèce de
grand mouvement d'expansion les pays
sous développés vers l'année culture nos
compétences et nos moyens en même temps
que nous les valorisons d'ailleurs il ya
certes non pas une stagnation de
l'agriculture européenne mais il ya un
certain ralentissement de son expansion
et nous pensons que nous pouvons
valoriser nos techniques les matériels
les produits français
en amorçant de nouveaux mouvements à
l'étranger alors ceci correspond à ce
que nous avons fait en irak en
association au fond avec le gouvernement
irakien août pour le compte du
gouvernement irakien qui nous l'avait
commandé et c'est pour nous en effet une
très importante étape une ferme clé en
main qui coûte combien
c'est un gros investissement c'est une
ferme qui représente de l'ordre de 120
millions de francs
vous avez beaucoup d'autres projets
comme celui-ci nous avons plusieurs
projets en s'appuyant en particulier sur
cette expérience qui est en situé en
plein coeur de la mésopotamie constitue
évidemment un centre d'intérêt
particulier pour l'ensemble des pays du
moyen orient
toutes les installations sont
ultramodernes la ferme dans n'occupe pas
moins 150 personnes et pour trois ans
six experts français qui assure la mise
en route
15 cents hectares sont déjà mises en
culture pour un projet de 2000 hectares
l'irrigation réalisé par la france
permet au bout d'un an seulement
d'obtenir de bonnes récoltes de luzerne
d'orge de sorgho et de maïs
les aliments sont préparés sur place
avec les récoltes dans une véritable
usine de transformation
entièrement automatisé sol des
compléments sont fournies par la firme
française sander ce elle aussi filiale
de mc d'autres matériels viennent de
france comme les deux salles de traite
et les outils de travail du sol et de
récolte
avec la ferme la société peq engineering
à la charge de construire un village qui
doit abriter 500 personnes et comprendra
bien entendu une école
situé à proximité d'un village
traditionnel au coeur d'une palmeraie
c'est l'image de la vie moderne
le contraste entre l'agriculture d'hier
et celle de demain
il est toutefois raisonnable d'imaginer
que l'avenir sera fait d'un compromis
entre ces deux formes de vie afin d'
éviter un changement trop brutal des
coutures